I develop my name is Jackie from Matt
Brian labs I'd like to know what the
evolutionary advantage is in growing old
and in dining they are biologically
immortal animals on this planet so what
is the evolutionary advantage for us to
grow old and die surely the immortal
animals should ever the better shot or a
better chance at survival long term to
survive as a species Jeffrey it would be
great maybe to be immortal but nobody
seems to be I don't know if you if
you're familiar with this I'm you know
I'm of a certain age I pay taxes you
can't get away from they have to pay
taxes the other thing that it's clearly
true and inescapable is you're gonna die
I'm the first to admit it kind of sucks
first to admit but the reason we all got
this far as our ancestors had kids I had
you for example and this just seems to
be the way of the world
the thing about evolution that is so
wonderful
and so troubling is you don't have to be
extraordinary you do not have to be this
super organism the Superman superwoman
super mushroom super palm-tree all you
have to be is good enough you have to be
good enough to pass your genes on and
there is no reason as far as anybody can
tell there's no reason in nature for
natural systems to produce something
that's better than good enough if it
happens it happens but there's no reason
if you if you're not good enough you get
eliminated your genes don't show up in
the future but if you're good enough
they do just think of all the troubling
people you meet all the people you think
wow wouldn't it be better if they
weren't around I'm sorry man they were
good enough as are you and I that's a
great question so what it does for me is
this knowledge that we're gonna die you
just try to make the best of every day I
mean there's gonna be hard times
be difficult times there's almost
certainly you're gonna get sick from
time to time because the germs and the
viruses and parasites the bacteria
they're out to get you man but with all
that you just try to make the best of
every day because you only get so many